tenemos que encontrar el área
superficial de esta figura que tenemos
aquí que se conoce como un cono truncado
o un tronco aunque yo lo llamo cubeta
porque tiene esa forma un círculo grande
y un círculo pequeño conectados de esta
forma aquí nos señalan algunas medidas y
nos interesa esta área superficial en
particular que es el área del cono
porque yo sé que puedo obtener si es
necesario el área de este círculo grande
y el área de este círculo pequeño así
que la pregunta específica es cuál es
esta área superficial cómo hacemos esto
la idea principal es que observamos este
ángulo podemos imaginar que esto está
formado por dos conos uno grande del
cual se ha quitado un cono más pequeño
porque conozco la fórmula del área de un
cono tipo r por l así que puedo calcular
el área del cono más grande y después
restarle el área del cono más pequeño
así obtengo esto esta va a ser la
estrategia pero hay unas longitudes
faltantes no necesito esta longitud del
cono más grande y también necesito estar
y tú del cono más pequeño así que
primero necesito usar los datos que nos
proporcionan para encontrar esas
longitudes faltantes y después usarlas
pausa en el vídeo y traten de encontrar
estas longitudes faltantes por su cuenta
y luego usen las en la fórmula para ver
qué resultados se obtienen primero voy a
etiquetar esto para saber a qué nos
referimos l 2 la necesito para definir
el área superficial del cono grande y
necesito l 1 para definir el área
superficial del cono pequeño pero para
hacerlo necesito encontrar h1 h2 porque
una vez que las encuentre puedo usar h 1
con el teorema de pitágoras y con el
lado de 6 centímetros para definir l 1 y
de esta forma también puedo encontrar el
2 el primer paso es encontrar h 1 como
encontramos h1 hice una observación en
la que este triángulo de aquí y este
triángulo de acá son semejantes ya que
sus lados son proporcionales voy a
describir sus proporciones h 1 es este
lado y el lado más grande se llama h 2
pero
la geometría aquí vemos que es h 14 es
este lado más este lado esto es
proporcional al 6 y el 9 6 / 9 ahora
tenemos una ecuación y una variable por
lo que la podemos resolver vamos a
hacerlo haremos una multiplicación
cruzada y nos quedan nueve por h1 que es
igual a 6 por h 1 + 6 por 4 que es 24 sé
que de este lado queda 31 y 24 entre 3
es igual a 8 por lo que h1 es igual a 8
centímetros sé que hice muchas
matemáticas mentales aquí pero pueden
verificarlo si quieren ir más despacio 3
h 1 aquí y 24 acá ahora que tengo h 1
aquí y que es igual a 8 centímetros
puedo calcular la longitud de todo esto
es 84 que es igual a 12 h 2 es igual a
12 centímetros ya hemos avanzado
bastante ahora sólo necesitamos aplicar
el teorema de pitágoras vamos a hacerlo
para encontrar l1 y l2
primero encontremos l 1 l 1 va a ser
igual a la raíz cuadrada de 6 al
cuadrado más h 1 al cuadrado que es 8 al
cuadrado sabemos que esto es igual a 36
más 64 la raíz cuadrada de esto y esto
es igual a 30 más 60 es 96 más 4 es 10
por lo que es la raíz cuadrada de 100
que es igual a 10 l 1 es igual a 10
centímetros en general los números que
se obtienen aquí no tienen que ser tan
bonitos como los de este ejemplo por lo
que no siempre tendremos un resultado
tan bonito como éste aquí pudimos tener
un número que no tiene una raíz cuadrada
perfecta y el resultado puede verse en
menos bonito pero el objetivo de estos
vídeos no es probar que ustedes sepan
cómo encontrar la raíz cuadrada sino
comprender cómo encontrar estos números
para calcular el área de un tronco o de
un cono truncado
en resumen pueden encontrarse problemas
cuyos números no resulten tan bonitos
como estos pero no piensen que se
equivocaron si están haciendo los pasos
correctos
l 2 es igual a la raíz cuadrada de h 2
al cuadrado que es 12 al cuadrado más el
radio al cuadrado que es 9 centímetros
al cuadrado esto es igual a 12 al
cuadrado es 144 más 9 al cuadrado es 81
el resultado final es igual a la raíz
cuadrada de aquí también es la raíz
cuadrada 225 y su raíz cuadrada es igual
a 15 por lo que r2 es igual a 15
centímetros ahora ya tenemos todas las
longitudes que necesitamos y noten que
aún no usamos una fórmula específica
para el cono truncado yo encuentro esta
forma de hacerlo más intuitiva por lo
que ahora sólo tenemos que restar el
área del cono más pequeño del área del
cono más grande cuál es el área
superficial del cono más grande es igual
aquí por ere 2 por l 2 r2 se refiere a
este 9 - people r 1 por l 1 esto nos
dará esta área que es lo que queremos
vamos a hacer lo reescribimos como 22
entre 7 y
multiplicamos por ere 2 por l 2 - r 1
por l 1 que es 9 por l 2 que es 15 - r 1
por l 1 que r 16 y l 1 es 10 y esto es
todo dependiendo del número que nos den
esto puede verse más complicado pero
aquí elegimos los números para que no
resultaran tan complicados 9 x 15 es 9
por 5 que es 45 + 9 por 10 que es 90 +
45 es igual a 135 menos 6 por 10 y 60
aquí tenemos 22 entre 7% 35 menos 60 es
igual a 75 aquí ustedes pueden calcular
el resultado aunque no es el objetivo de
este ejemplo el resultado va a ser
cercano a 200 veintitantos ya que este
cociente se parece mucho a 10 y las
unidades van a ser centímetros cuadrados
pero la idea principal aquí es que para
calcular el área del tronco toman el
cono grande encuentran las longitudes
del cono grande
chicos para luego poder usar la fórmula
del área superficial del cono